the number of illegal aliens streaming
across our border has just hit a new
all-time record never before have we
seen anything like this more than a
quarter of a million foreign Nationals
were stopped last month alone
so that's an invasion there's no other
word for it it's having an effect on
every part of American life it's having
an effect on farmers
Alex Mueller is a farmer in Yuma Arizona
the president of the pasquinelli produce
company he joins us tonight to tell us
what he has firsthand been experiencing
Alex thanks so much for coming on
um so we don't hear often enough from
people in border states about what it
looks like to them what's your
experience been
well hello Tucker thanks for having me
um it's over the last two years it's
just been a death by a Thousand Cuts
it's been a slow Trickle
um and we're seeing it every day we're
right this is the end of the Border here
and we have a field of lettuce here
and uh the community here has seen an
uptick in crossers and it's just been
continuous and continuous and it's
taxing and it's hard for us to do our
jobs when we we take food safety as as
at the utmost uh for what we do and
anytime anybody enters our field we have
to Cordon that off and flag it and we
don't
um Harvest that area just like if a
coyote enters our field we can't Harvest
that area so when there's 20 people 30
people but sometimes there's a hundred
out there
about a quarter mile down mostly they
cross but there's gaps along the wall
that they're crossing over and it's it's
it's it's an additional aspect of our
job that is sort of out of our
wheelhouse
well you shouldn't have to contend with
border security or lettuce farmer the
state and the federal government should
be doing that for you that's their main
job that's why they exist are they and
and why aren't they apparently they're
not
well no they're they're not and and
we're you know we live on a board we
live in a border community and the
border patrol are our friends and the
border patrol are are glorified uh uh uh
travel agency now and you know they're
they're people cross the down here a
quarter mile
and border patrol comes down and they
put people in buses they take them to a
tent city that where the border patrol
station is there's probably 5 000 people
there at any given time and they're
giving them bus passes or airplane
tickets and they're flying all over the
country and it's uh it's been insane to
watch for the last two years and it's
it's something that
we need help down here and and uh we
want to we want to bring light to this
situation
of course you're so meticulous in your
job that you just told us if a coyote
crosses into your field you will not
sell the produce the coyote touched so
how does it feel the produce and right
but so here's the government abetting
crime the people are supposed to be
stopping the crime are making it
possible rewarding the crime with free
airline tickets as an American how does
it feel
well at a time you know we're coming out
of the pandemic and at a time when all
of it costs across the border up our our
freight costs are up double fuel costs
are up 30 percent input costs are up 30
percent it's an additional cost that it
gets sent down to the to the end user
the American public and we're very proud
of what we do my my wife's family has
been farming here for 75 years and we're
one of the young guys on the Block and
and
we're proud of this we're proud of what
we provide to the American people and
this has been going on for two years
it's not stopping I mean I can tell you
anecdotally a couple stories where
they're a border patrol agent friend of
mine saw somebody Crossing that had two
people crossing with him that he was
paying to carry his Louis Vuitton
luggage
and then on the same hand I've seen a
little girl Crossing that was a
five-year-old with a phone number
pinned to her chest and she was alone I
saw that with my own eyes and it's been
going on for two years
and we need help down here it's not
something that it's in our wheelhouse
it's not something the city of Yuma
needs to deal with of course yeah we'd
like to get some help
I hope you get it this is an atrocity
such an expression deep disrespect for
our Niche thank you um Alex thank you so
much for joining us tonight
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight